hola bienvenidos a todos una vez más a
este espacio canal en las américas café
correspondiente al 15 de febrero de 2019
15 16 y 17 como ustedes saben en línea
durante todo el fin de semana para que
el placer sea no sea tan corto pero que
sea largo
exacto perfecto saludamos a todos los
que nos siguen a través de nuestros
diferentes canales de comunicación
facebook live youtube rcn todo todo esto
sea barra la medicación la aplicación
que la vamos a recordar también en un
poco tiempo más por un lado o por el
otro o sea por lo que sea por internet
la sesión de chistes o el chiste
ahora la gente
hay un montón de soldados y un capitán
que llega
y dice soldados muy buena práctica y le
dice a uno que no si mi capitán no lo
voy a hacer en la práctica de camuflar
camuflaje muchas gracias porque tanto
aunque ustedes tienen media hora misión
el que hay entendido de chiste si hay
alguien por ahí
[Risas]
no entendemos nada puede ser también más
allá de este trago amargo entonces le
damos la bienvenida a todos los que lo
siguen como cada semana en este espacio
que les proponemos desde el servicio en
español de radio canadá internacional y
a quienes nos siguen en nuestra página
internet a quienes lo hacen a través de
www hereje y net punto sea hoy podrán
escuchar dos temas musicales de un
cantante canadiense de la ciudad de
toronto que ella
daniel si se te gusta personalmente al
respecto pero sí que es muy lindo porque
porque vamos a pasar música de años y
soy porque me digan un premio porque es
el día de la ensalada
así salgado un premio efectivamente días
pasados en la entrega de los premios
grammy esos premios que se entregan a
los más son los más importantes de
industria musical mundial dos grammy y
no los gremlins
y él ganó en la categoría de
interpretación vocal de un tema del
rythm blues
vamos a escuchar o van a escuchar que
nos sigue a través del sitio en internet
dos temas uno de ellos ballets como
violeta más autóctono y es la mejor
parte amarillo por ejemplo a internet
ahí tendrán la música de danny cesar sí
está muy difícil como ustedes saben
además esta semana más precisamente el
miércoles 13 de febrero se celebró el
día internacional o el día mundial de la
radio así señor
[Risas]
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bueno ese audio que acaban de escuchar
tiene que ver con los orígenes de la
radio como ustedes saben hay varios
países que se disputan haber sido la
cuna de la radiodifusión entre ellos
están estados unidos rusia gran bretaña
y se suma a ese mejor que el de
argentina porque porque enrique telémaco
susini en el año 1920 tengo otra fecha
aquí exacta 27 de agosto de 1920 realizó
una transmisión desde el teatro coliseo
de buenos aires- de la ópera parsifal de
wagner y para muchos estudiosos del tema
esa fue la primera emisión la primera
transmisión del radio como tal poco
después se hizo a cabo una transmisión
se llevó a cabo mejor está una
transmisión de radio en eeuu que es la
que es aceptada internacionalmente como
la primera emisión pero cronológicamente
la inicial llega de wessin y fue primero
exactamente y porque se celebra el 13 de
febrero el día mundial de la radio
porque en esa fecha en el año 46 si no
me falla la memoria
se inauguró la radio de naciones unidas
naciones unidas comenzó a transmitir a
través de su estación radial entonces
este gremio que tiene esta actividad la
llave que tiene tantos años de
existencia a la que nosotros nos sumamos
en su época como muy alegres mente
además y hoy nos da de comer y muy
orgullosamente es uno de los medios como
ustedes saben más expandido por el mundo
que a lo largo de su historia ha sufrido
un proceso de transformación ha vivido
por 900 negativamente un proceso de
transformación importantísimo hoy está
perfilado más que nada la difusión
digital a través de internet y por
supuesto ligado a esa difusión por
internet les recordamos que todos
ustedes tienen a disposición la
aplicación de radio canadá internacional
de la que hablaba el leonardo unos
instantes y que pueden ver a partir de
esa aplicación neonato para qué sirve
esa aplicación en realidad es el primero
mucho más rápida que el sitio de
internet tal como lo vemos hoy
después está condensada o sea que
muestra y está repartida digamos la
información de una manera mucho más
fácil esto es para que no pueda acceder
a la información más rápidamente después
poner tiene toda la información que
nosotros vamos produciendo durante todos
los días y hace una semana también se
habilitó la posibilidad de ver este
programa en vivo y en directo a partir
de la aplicación entonces para las dos
plataformas disponibles en apple store y
en google play pueden entrar a nuestro
sitio y hacer clic en alguno de los dos
iconos que muestran estos dos servicios
y de ahí en adelante uno hace un clic
por ejemplo vamos al postor y en este
caso está vinculado directamente con
radio canadá internacional en español
porque estamos lanzando a partir del
sitio en español
en el sitio en inglés para google play
tiene que buscar en español y lo adentro
de la aplicación todas las aplicaciones
están en lenguas extranjeras como por
ejemplo la nuestra tiene la posibilidad
de ir directamente al contenido en
francés y en inglés a partir de la
aplicación en español pasa lo mismo con
las otras lenguas por ejemplo cuando es
en chino tiene inglés francés cuando ese
árabe tiene inglés francés cuando es
inglés tiene francés y español y cuando
es francés tiene inglés española o sea
tenemos la presencia en las aplicaciones
en otras lenguas también así que los
invitamos a sumarse y a bajar la
aplicación de cualquiera de estas dos
platas decimos que la radio fusión
cambia y radio canadá internacional
entonces cambia también sigue ese
proceso ustedes nos escuchaban antes a
través de la onda corta servicio que fue
suspendido en el año 2012 ahora tienen
diversas vías para acceder muchísimas
opciones para acceder entre ellas esta
aplicación y también la difusión por
podcast que es justamente que pueden
bajar la el programa de nosotros del
programa semana al nuestro a su teléfono
y escucharlo mientras van caminando por
ahí bicicleteando por ahí
cuando nieve por ahí también bueno
hilario la radio como decía ha sido
importante es importante para todos
nosotros porque trabajamos aquí que para
los oyentes que desde hace años nos
siguen a través de distintos canales de
difusión lo decíamos recién a través de
onda corta ahora en la era digital cada
uno de nosotros debe tener recuerdos de
cómo llegó a la radio ya sea como como
consumidor o como profesional trabajador
del medio puede ser primer recuerdo que
tiene la radio pablo de radio canadá
internacional de la radio mira yo era un
niño estaba en barranquilla debía tener
por ahí como unos 6 o 7 años más o menos
y en
en el barrio había un amigo que le
gustaba mucho inventar cosas entonces él
agarró un tablero de estos que se
conocen mucho en américa latina' estos
tableros metálicos de cocacola no
entonces él había agarrado ese tablero y
se había subido el frente a su casa
había un árbol muy grande y él se subió
al árbol y fue a amarrar ese letrero de
metal allá arriba lo más alto que pudo
de ese árbol le puso un alambre
lo perforó y le puso un alambre que
bajaba a unos audífonos como los que
tenemos acá en este momento y
barranquilla con ese sol y con brisa y
todo entonces captábamos ondas radiales
no teníamos absolutamente ningún control
o sea nosotros lo único que hacíamos era
que nos poníamos los audífonos y
escuchado lo que recibimos que recibiera
por intermedio de sant en a llanera en
el tradicional era una escena muy
improvisada y ese fue el primer contacto
digamos personal así en el que yo estuve
participando con este amigo
en la radio ahora bien en la radio pues
es un medio muy importante en aquella
época también sobre todo en aquella
época en la sociedad colombiana no sea
porque permitía comunicarse con personas
no había teléfono o sea había teléfono
pero muchos hogares no tenían teléfonos
entonces era la forma de comunicarse con
familiares que vivían por ejemplo en el
campo y si tú ibas a viajar al campo es
ya pasaba su mensajito en la radio
diciendo bueno fulanito
les advierto que sutanito se sube en el
bus aquí en barranquilla y llega al
pueblo más o menos a tal hora que por
favor de aliste los burros y vayan a
buscar mensajes bien algunos lugares se
siguen utilizando tú no es que porque
aparece luego el teléfono luego internet
o antes de internet la televisión esos
mensajes dejaron de producirse hasta el
día de hoy esos mensajes siguen siendo
muy importante sobre todo para las
comunidades rurales en muchas partes y
esa fue mi relación digamos así se
inició mi relación con la radio que
continúa todavía hoy en día
desde otra óptica de otras mamás yo
transformada muy bien paloma ya en el
recuerdo de la radio yo recuerdo en mi
abuelo mi abuelo tenía una huerta muy
grande de hoy no muy grande pero tena
era como larga era como profunda era un
terreno que tenía ahí y cultivaba toda
clase de cosas cosechaba también en unas
épocas del año y recuerdo mi abuelo que
se que se que se paseaba por esa huerta
siempre con un radiecito pequeñito
entonces íbamos yo
y él iba escuchando la radio y luego me
decía escuchaste y entonces tengo esos
recuerdos de haber pasado muchas horas
caminando por esa huerta con mi abuelo y
su radio citó que fue tan consumida en
todas partes del mundo y particularmente
en américa latina y que a muchos les
permitió seguir la actualidad los
encuentros de fútbol de sus clubes
favoritos el béisbol es muy popular y me
recuerdo que encuentro las finales de
las grandes ligas los yanquis contra los
dodgers de los ángeles y bueno pues ahí
lo has escuchado a la gente tú lo sigo
viendo con el radio pegado a la oreja y
escuchando los programas muy bien
su primer recuerdo de la radio
justamente
mi papá trabajaba en la radio locutor en
radio televisión en san rafael mendoza
en argentina y voy a pretender que es la
época en la radio siempre fue parte de
la familia no era para que trabajaba la
radio su productora que hacía su
programa de radio y tal así que siempre
hubo una relación muy especial por una
cosa que me acuerdo en papá era en las
noches en su virgen tonomac que se abría
la puerta y que te enseñaba para mondi
en las radios siete madres y el
sintonizaba radio onda corta y ya hemos
escuchado en aquella época te estoy
hablando tenía 89 años aproximadamente y
hemos escuchado
transmisiones donde corta radio canadá
internacional de la bbc de londres en
espantos en español mi papá también
escuchaba las las que estaban en inglés
de la deutsche welle
así que bueno esas radios como siempre
fue una parte muy especial en nuestra
familia el tema de la radio después
bueno me fui a pegando a ella y a
estudiante ha podido despegar
cuál era la emisora en la que trabajaba
tu papá
y si no me equivoco se le ve 15 si no me
equivoco pero no recuerdo bien me
acuerdo que tenía en la productora queda
con alonso alonso gimeno al fin que era
la productora con la que hacían los
contenidos de los programas y buscaban
sus publicidades y tal trabajaban en
aquella época se te estoy hablando hace
muchísimos años atrás así que bueno
siempre la relación de la radio estado
muy pegadita al familiar y tu luis
laborda bueno yo recuerdo pasar horas y
horas y horas de mi infancia
adolescencia y ya no tan adolescente
escuchando radio el recuerdo más antiguo
que tengo que es el de siendo muy
pequeño no sé exactamente qué edad
escuchar me apasionaba escuchar onda
corta en una vieja radio que tenían en
el dormitorio mis padres y a la tarde
cuando ese dormitorio estaba libre yo me
sentaba al costado de esa radio una
radio enorme con válvulas que había que
esperar que se calentará para que
funcionase
escuchaba las transmisiones de onda
corta entre otras por ejemplo del radio
moscú una época en la que existía aún la
unión soviética donde era acceder a un
mundo desconocido misterioso totalmente
distinto un mundo que conoce a este años
más tarde conocí más garbellano en la
unión soviética siendo una rusia actual
escuchaba a otras emisoras de onda corta
también y luego importante también como
recuerdo como mi padre también como en
el caso de una lo trabajaba en medios de
comunicación fue periodista yo conocí la
radio desde dentro de muy pequeño a
veces mi padre me llevaba con él a la
emisora radial en la que trabajaba en
buenos aires y mientras él trabajaba yo
me dedicaba a jugar en la radio para mí
jugar en esa radio era por ejemplo ir a
la sala de teletipos que existían en esa
época todavía cortar los cables
acercarse o sea alguien en la redacción
para que los viera y dimitan contar los
cables yo creía que era cortando los voy
a arruinar la radio
nos contábamos con esa adversidad todos
en teletipos se imprimía la noticia en
papeles eso es el famoso cable de
agencias de noticias con que se iba
luego al estudio porque eran muy pocos
los periodistas que elaboraban la
noticia antes de estudios se leían el
cable se modificaba en el aire ese cable
es los redactaba medicinalmente
en vivo y uno estaba presente y viendo
todo ese proceso que para mí era mágico
en buena medida así que ese es mi
recuerdo más viejo más importante más
trascendente en relación con las noches
y ustedes pero cuando uno es chiquito
uno juegas los ladrones de policía lo
jugaba que hacíamos que estábamos en la
radio así que nosotros experiencias
cuáles son sus vivencias cuál es la
importancia que para ustedes ha tenido
la radio supongo que ha de ser
importante si no siguen aquí fielmente
cada religiosa me dice el zamora dice
saludos desde esa tierra yo soy uno de
quienes los siguen desde los tiempos de
onda corta en el caso de saludos a todos
con un programa se extraña a leonora
saludos y vuelve bueno que nos un
segundito nada más y ya volvemos
[Música]
o no
en el primer capítulo de nuestra misión
y no nos reclaman la atención porque
tienen un mensaje si dice ese rodríguez
jarr y dice díganme a mí de las
emisiones de anda cortado también en
compañía de mi padre con una radio cenit
siempre con esa ilusión de trabajar en
una radio internacional ese mundo que te
lleva a muchos mundos hoy vía internet
saludos desde bogotá y sueños
y pasando al siguiente segmento de la
emisión cuáles son las noticias que les
han llamado la atención las noticias
poco convencionales fuera de lo común
que les han sorprendido en estos días yo
no los convencionales
yo no sé si es poco convencional es
decir restringiendo demasiado a la gente
que todo el mundo le dice a la gente que
es el 14 de febrero y que es el 14 de
febrero el amor y la amistad
y el 15 de febrero que es el día
siguiente es el día de la bandera el día
de la bandera todos nos acordamos del
amor y el amor pues muchos países como
los de américa latina que celebra más
tal vez
y ustedes saben bueno ustedes
seguramente lo saben no sé si lo saben
nuestros oyentes de que existe un
listado al cual los ciudadanos no sé si
los residentes nos de seguro ahora pero
seguramente los ciudadanos seguros y los
ciudadanos de canadá se pueden inscribir
para después de un tiempo equis que
suelen ser algunas décadas recibir una
de las banderas que a flameado en el
frente del parlament
y te inscribiste pero se demora unos
cuantos años hay que inscribirse y
partidos inscritos tiene que saber que
tiene que esperar unos 20 o 25 años
joven
cuando las cambian y no estoy tan seguro
eso yo creo que es en el parlamento yo
creo que es una bandera por semana no
estoy seguro si sé que el listado de
gente que se inscribe es larguísimo de
allí que la espera es tan larga también
personal pero a cada uno que se inscribe
le da una bandera no no no a uno se
inscribe en esa lista y después por
orden de llegada le van dando la bandera
pero no sé si la mente alcanza para todo
el mundo no estoy seguro de la
perioricidad ahora que paloma lo
pregunta yo creo que es una bandera por
semana la que se cambia que como ustedes
saben se guisa todos los días en el
parlamento pero se la cambia una vez por
semana habrá que checar ese dato no
estoy tan seguro y esa bandera una vez
que se baja
definitivamente no se utilizan no se
pueden ensuciar ni lavar en este caso
hay que seguir un proceso especial de
destrucción porque es un símbolo de la
nación es un símbolo patrio como se dice
en américa latina y en este caso uno de
los recursos que ha pensado que pensaron
en su momento las autoridades
canadienses fue el de entregar esa
bandera a un ciudadano que la quiera
custodiar entre comillas que la quiera
tener en su mundo y en su casa porque la
bandera que existe en el parlamento es
bastante bueno en un tercer piso de la
torre del parlamento canadiense de estos
gigantes a la gente en toronto tirando
sillas por los balcones porque no
colgaban de las grandes que tú querías
ver con la bandera no no no nada que ver
con la radio tampoco de hecho es mayor
la iglesia es un cura que estaba medio
medio borracho o sea muchos vinos de
misa antes de las misas
entonces pues llega y está están todos
los feligreses de pie en y el padre
entra y se los queda mirando
feliz dios lo bendiga
setecientos mil monos
todo el mundo de su vida
mira que la gente reacciona raro 70.000
monos dice la gente todavía más
desconcertada
el padre dice setecientos monos
nada no pasa nada finalmente dice
sentémonos
[Risas]
[Música]
bueno entonces te invitamos a nuestros
pacientes quienes sigan que les quieren
que este show del chiste siga que
empezamos a comentar paloma que quería
comentar la super gigantesca y tormenta
de nieve de esta semana el miércoles
entre el martes y el miércoles de esta
semana una tormenta invernal increíble
casi en todo canadá no solamente las
regiones en donde siempre nieva es
alguien que haga exactamente todo estuvo
incluso en columbia virginia
exacto entonces hubo muchísima nieve en
montreal y en varias regiones de quebec
entre 40 y 50 centímetros de nieve
cayeron y tenemos imágenes leonado que
además filmó pablo que me impresionaron
de gente a ver si lo encuentras que
utilizo la tormenta de nieve en un
sentido positivo digamos no se dejó
sobrellevar por la adversidad que puede
haber provocado esa tormenta que arrojó
muchísimo nieve que sigue arrojando
porque esta mañana cuando salí de casa
todavía estaba nevando quiere decir de
que hubo un descanso pero todavía hay
algunos copos por ahí perdidos en la
atmósfera que se precipitaron esta
mañana y bueno pues van a caer algunos
cuantos centímetros todavía bueno y la
tormenta dio entonces espacio a la
creatividad a la creatividad y al
ingenio
la idea es que se paralizó todo por
varias horas bueno es decir nosotros no
nos paralizados porque aquí estaba muy
bien puestos trabajar algunas imágenes
que yo encontramos estas son algunas esa
no la firmó pablo pero está buena
también miren a los pobres policías
tratando de empujar su
bloqueados ahí la innovación la
persecución estos son algunas personas y
personas yendo a la escuela hoy paseando
nomás por la calle en esquina porque no
había otra manera de pasear y bueno eso
y más abajo si vemos en ese mismo en ese
mismo artículo que escribimos al
respecto hay una imagen ésta es la que
pablo firmó aquí en la esquina del
actual trabajo nomás sobre la pantalla
de completarse padre esto se va a acabar
porque es rapidito
ellos van por la calle rtve que estoy
aquí
llx wood y que lo que caminamos nos
dimos cuenta que era dificultoso cambiar
el miércoles era más aconsejable salir
realmente con esquís que con calzado
convencional porque nos hundíamos en la
nieve tan pro que el triple de tiempo en
hacer la misma distancia que todos los
taxis habitualmente tarda 10 minutos
ahora tardó media hora en decirse la
mitra
no sé si pusiste la limpieza de la calle
también cuatro camiones juntos mirando
la nieve para el costado ahora un día
después las calles las arterias por lo
menos las más grandes las más utilizadas
cero nieve serán bien pregunta bien por
mi calle mi calle cita está muy hoy lo
comentábamos con pablo esta mañana
cuando llegamos muy temprano yo vivo en
la ribera sur de montreal en mi
localidad que se llama rozar parece ser
que por alguna cuestión climatológica
existencial
las veredas no se pueden limpiar pero en
santander las veredas que son los
andenes que le llaman por ahí los
peatones
pero en colombia una vereda no es una
antena una vereda es una parte del
cambio en méxico no es una vereda es una
de los pasajeros para subir al tren
vuelo prensa lambert que está pegado a
rosas de hecho de una avenida y mar que
divide procesar the sun lambert las
veredas estaban o los andenes estaban
impecables que cambiar se hagan más
caros como puestos más en la avenida sin
mar cambia el clima así como alguna vez
alguien explicó de que en canadá las
sean destruidas y en mal estado y en
eeuu las frutos están en perfecto estado
alguna vez alguien me explicó que es
porque en la frontera en el donde está
el peaje ahí cambia el clima
diferentes frío que golpea al frente
caliente y si tengo más saludos en este
caso bueno saludos comentarios se
desarrollaría charly dice que bueno su
comentario anterior de su relación con
la radio por ello estudió periodismo
gracias a la radio internacional javier
gonzález nunca nos dice saludos para
todos
gustavo lucas dice buenas tardes quiero
compartir un recuerdo en relación al
radio canal internacional para que
tengan una idea desde cuánto hace que
les escucho quiero mencionar a alguien
que trabajaba en el cdy en esa época se
trata de susana peñas de vida un saludo
desde melo en uruguay
porque unos 15 o 18 años que se jubiló
si de hecho cuando yo comencé ya no
trabajaba en asunción yo comencé hace 16
y ya algún tema que te haya llamado la
atención esta semana sí muy muy
rápidamente es en el bueno ayer ya todo
el mundo lo sabe fue
la san valentín entonces en el zoológico
de calgary para festejar este día
entonces le dieron alimentos a los
animales no a todos pero entre otros a
los pandas a los pingüinos a las nutrias
a los gorilas le dieron algunos
caramelos pero no eran caramelos sino
por ejemplo lula no eran dulces pero el
perdón por ejemplo a los pandas le
dieron llames en forma de flores
es un tubérculo como la papa como la
yuca
[Risas]
los animales estaban muy muy muy
contentos y decían en el zoológico que
están estos pequeños estos pequeños
regalitos estos pequeños artículos
alientan el comportamiento natural y
ofrecen a los animales una nueva forma
de estimulación por amor y amor para los
animales también fue ayer acá en el
zoológico de calgary bueno yo por mi
parte muy brevemente le voy a comentar
una noticia que me llamó la atención
porque primero el hecho de sencilla
motivo y segundo el objeto que se robó
es más llamativo todavía al menos ahora
a mí en terranova la policía investiga
el robo de 30.000 litros de agua de
icebergs o de témpano la señora de donde
robaron bueno el tema
yo no sabía lo descubrí leyendo este
artículo el hecho ocurrió en la ciudad
costera de port y unión en allí en en
terranova
y se trata de un producto que es usado
frecuentemente para la producción de
distintos productos comerciales valga la
redundancia entre ellos el vodka o sea
que quien se robó estos 30 minutos de
agua afectó a los bebedores de vodka que
no podrán tenerlos
entre otras cosas un beneficio por ahí
algún papel de vodka grande de estilo
que necesitaba agua de icebergs y usa
además por ejemplo palomas ya que lo
decías para producir agua embotellada de
lujo que esa agua embotellada que cuesta
carísima algunos supermercados de lujo
está producida por 'the guardian'
efectivamente y yo no sabía que los
extras se cultivan donde se produce un
reporte donde se producen dos icebergs
para luego ir cercando les parte de esos
esos saberes that we una lírica paz sean
dir el agua y esa es agua se deposita en
un lugar que con estaba depositada en el
momento en que se produjo este robo para
luego venderlo a la industria por
ejemplo del vodka
de lujo etcétera etcétera alguien se dio
cuenta como decía pablo que esto es un
negocio fructífero y se robó los 30.000
litros de agua de icebergs que la
policía está investigando está buscando
un camión cisterna oa un remolque de
tractor y hasta ahora no tienen mayores
pistas pero por ejemplo esa agua se
vende a todo el mundo entre otros países
a china korea y agrave y arabia saudita
y un robo también que me llamó mucho la
atención pero que pero ya sea tiempo un
antecedente de en esta línea de robos es
extraño si es en el año 2012 se robaron
18 millones de dólares en una mercadería
también muy preciada aquí en canadá que
es cuál
el cielo se robaron jarabe de arce por 8
millones de dólares
en miel de maple plata dulce las
noticias llamativas de esta semana son
el mensaje por favor tengo mensajes está
smile samoré dice en algún tiempo dice
mandaba colaboraciones para el reportero
un día comentando tradiciones de mi
ciudad si nosotros nos acordamos si hay
cosas en el archivo todavía de esos
reporteros un día se cerró de béchar
dice en la vereda tropical dice la
canción hablando de la vereda tropical y
fm radio jotas son los éxitos dice
felicitaciones a radio canadá
internacional bueno les cuento que la
primera emisión de radio en américa fue
en barranquilla
el 8 de diciembre de 1929 en la
h de de la voz de barranquilla gracias
al ingeniero elías jp le traigo por eso
es barranquilla considerada como la cuna
de la radio
pero malambo su utilidad transmisión de
sus hijos fue en 1920 así que yo creo
que tiene que ver con las transmisiones
probablemente sean
la transmisión continua es como el de
leche la nuestra fue de todo el mundo
alimento dulce leche es asiático no sé
cuántos miles antes años de cristo y
desquició
había más allá del uso de leche un
mensaje de los 800 dice toronto para el
reportaje toronto ciudad santuario para
refugiados e indocumentados gilberto
podrás comenta entonces quién los
entiende
al rato más violencia más narcotráfico
más niños desaparecidos más fraude
etcétera polo aquí hay un comentario
actual tema trabajadores temporales que
sufren abusos de sus empleadores podrían
cambiar de empleo de ottawa y juan godoy
dice muchas gracias por prevenir abusos
de autoridades como de empresas abusivas
estaría atento a sus noticias antes de
darle paso a leonardo yo agradezco la
correspondencia que nos llegó por el
servicio postal a nuestros oyentes
rafael reyes que es de santiago de cuba
en cuba por supuesto a rafael progensa
grites creo que es el apellido que es de
mayabeque en la habana también tengo
aquí otra carta que nos hizo llegar a
casa ya lo dije y aquí rafael reyes
también de santiago de cuba
muchas gracias por seguir mandando nos
cartas a través del correo postal
leonard tema viral de ese vídeo viral de
oso polar esquelético podría no ser lo
que parece es la noticia
isla y leslie vianney dice porque no lo
ayudaron no importa si está viejo pero
es un animal yo soy una niña que ve a un
animal mal lo intentó al lugar pero no
puedo dice porque soy una niña y si yo
fuera ustedes lo ayudaría en lugar de
grabar ustedes intentan sacar una
información en lugar de salvar la vida
de este animal
quien lo grabó estoy muy enojada con él
y por el otro lado triste lloro por todo
al que tiene a alguien al que quien
tiene la ayuda para ofrecer así que
bueno este es el mensaje de leslie
dayana nosotros también estamos muy
enojados con ese vídeo sexo
[Música]
y sexual
pero
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y de vuelta ya no nos queda tanto tiempo
tenemos toda la tarde pero aquí radio
visual
ustedes saben cada semana el equipo en
español produce reportajes entrevistas
etcétera etcétera etcétera y en cada
emisión les sugerimos uno de los temas
que cada uno de nosotros ha producido a
lo largo de esta semana así que aquí les
presentamos y ahora vamos a hacerlo el
tema sugerido de esta semana de cada uno
de los integrantes de equipo y presentes
quien quiere comenzar
como sabemos el ministerio de
inmigración de la provincia de québec de
la provincia francófona de que presentó
un proyecto de ley sobre la inmigración
recientemente y bueno hubo uno de los
temas en este proyecto de ley fue que 18
mil
el expediente de aspirantes a
inmigrantes serían eliminados
entonces les presentamos un reportaje
sobre las opciones que se presentan a
estos inmigrantes o aspirantes
inmigrantes aunque beck cuyo expediente
fue eliminado entonces hay tres opciones
las principales opciones son firmar una
petición para presentar su suba su
descontento al respecto otra opción nos
dice una abogada canadiense una abogada
que trata temas de inmigración
particularmente la opción otra opción es
legal puede uno demandar legalmente al
gobierno que deje mucho dinero y tiempo
invertido exactamente y otra cosa que es
la que ofrece el gobierno de quebec es
que sugiere a todos aquellos que habían
presentado su solicitud y que no hayan
recibido una respuesta de selección
rechazo rechazada o rechazo en el
momento en que se presentó que vuelvan a
presentar una declaración de interés
dentro de un programa particular que se
llama arrima y paren y que se sigan
informando sobre los programas los otros
programas de inmigración
bueno son tres opciones que se presentan
a todos aquellos que ya han cuyo
expediente fue eliminado que decir que
gran parte de estos o una buena parte de
8.000 expedientes corresponden a gente
que ya está instalada aquí en quebec que
la institución más problemática tural
exactamente porque siente que vino como
estudiante o que vino acompañando un
estudiante y entonces tienen un permiso
de trabajo o un permiso de estudios y
enviaron una solicitud pero que tienen
años viviendo aquí hay casos de gente de
hace dos desde el año 2005 que estaban
allí varados en el sistema entonces
bueno hay que son las tres opciones
si rápidamente en bueno hoy el mes de
febrero aquí en canadá se festeja el o
se conmemora más bien el mes de la
negritud la historia de la negritud que
todo el mes se hace todo tipo de
actividades y entre otras está este
toronto black film fest
que se organiza durante el mes y a este
festival hay un cineasta colombiano
jorge navas que envió su película que se
llama somos calentura que es una
película que fue
rodada en buenaventura en el puerto de
buenaventura en colombia en la costa
pacífica y que cuenta la historia de
cuatro de los muchachos de la juventud
finalmente afro afro colombiana de la
forma como viven y de las pocas
posibilidades que tienen porque esa
región del país ha sido tradicionalmente
olvidada por las clases políticas
entonces pues la gente vive en los
afrocolombianos que están ahí en ese
lugar viven prácticamente en la miseria
y este culo este cineasta jorge navas
hizo esta película sobre estos cinco
muchachos que la forma como ellos
quieren salir es con la música hip hop y
con la danza y bueno pues es toda la
temática al mismo tiempo que tratan de
sobresalir de sobrevivir con el arte
está también todo el mundo criminal por
debajo porque siendo un puerto con
aventura pues también todo lo que es
tráfico de mercancías ilegales
entra y sale por ahí entonces pues está
ese problema de que los muchachos
quieren salir y tienen que estar siempre
peleándose con el mundo y los criminales
que los quieren integrar a sus equipos
yo largos y menos si como le va el tema
de esta semana y un segundo por favor
no lo estaba pasando las imágenes de la
película bueno yo particularmente para
hoy el el tema de sordera y pérdida de
audición por el mal uso de los
auriculares sí una pandemia silenciosa
la organización mundial de salud llamó
la atención sobre esto como si porque no
en realidad y es y es una discapacidad
es una discapacidad oculta es una
discapacidad que uno realmente para
poder notar que si uno ve a alguien que
tiene no sé por ejemplo le falta un
brazo lo ve si algún ciego que se
desplaza lo de el tema de la audición
uno no ve hasta entré en contacto
entonces son esas discapacidades
invisibles que tanto existen y que uno
no sabe así que bueno la organización
mundial de la salud llama la atención
sobre esto pone el ojo sobre los
fabricantes y por supuesto hace una
serie de recomendaciones para lograr
adaptar los sistemas de los dispositivos
de tanto uso hoy en día
y prevenir este tipo de problemas que ya
se está transformando en una pandemia
sobre todo a partir del momento en que
los jóvenes bueno no solo los jóvenes
pero pero los jóvenes y los niños
también pasan horas y horas y horas
escuchando por ejemplo música a muy alto
volumen es a partir de sus teléfonos
móviles por ejemplo acá para algunas
cifras nadamas 466 millones de personas
en todo el mundo padecen pérdida de
audición discapacitante de las cuales
está a 100 34 millones son niños bueno
perfecto y por último yo le voy a
sugerir que accedan a una entrevista que
le dice al titular de unicef canadá
david morley de una información que ya
habíamos dado cuenta la semana anterior
en una noticia sobre el tema de que cada
vez hay más niños canadienses que
asisten a los bancos de alimentos para
poder prodigarse la comida que les
asegure su nutrición de manera adecuada
moli sostiene que esa mayor cantidad de
niños que asisten a los bancos de
alimentos tiene que ver con un aumento
de la pobreza en canadá y con también
los problemas que enfrentan las familias
canadienses para hacer frente a los
enormes gastos que tiene que ver con
mantener una familia
el país sobre todo tomando en cuenta que
una gran cantidad de familias
monoparentales es decir que tienen
solamente o padre o madre que debe
trabajar y asumir familia por supuesto
hacerse cargo de los alimentos aumentó
sobre todo en diseño que tienen allí la
entrevista a cristal de béisbol y
titular de unicef canadá a su
disposición no tenemos más tiempo por
hoy importante el último salud mientras
vamos escuchando la música de fondo
maría herrera des escuchándolos aquí
como siempre y después un mensaje de
radio cada internacional así que son
nosotros pero ahora les cuento dice
compañeros va un saludo sin trabajar
estoy como un león al que lo obligan a
ser vegetarianos
promocional
ciao es todo por hoy no tenemos más
tiempo nos decimos hasta la próxima y
gracias por estar una vez más con
nosotros a través de la vía que ustedes
emitan hasta la próxima
no